hey guys what's going on my name is
Jimmy Whisenhunt I'm a senior designer
here on h1z1 h1z1 is a game recently
announced by a Sony Online Entertainment
that's us and we're running through it
today and showing you guys a little bit
about it it is a post-apocalyptic
survival MMO persistent MMO throughout
the world things are going to be as you
expect them obviously one of the first
things you want to do when you get in
the game is craft something campfire is
important if you watch Bear Grylls or
any of those guys so we want it to be
exactly as you would expect you see a
tree you have an axe you're gonna chop
at the tree trees gonna fall and you're
gonna get some liberals so you can see
this is popping down right now we are in
a pre-alpha state right now so you'll
see some things pop up instantaneously
but you get the gist of it from there I
can actually go straight in crap things
like campfires and actually up here in
just a moment I'm going to do a little
bit of our discovery system crafting
within our game is probably one of the
most I would say intricate in best ways
to survive in the game so I'm going to
Rab the wood that I just had I'm going
to throw it in here I'm going to click
discover and it's going to tell me one
thing I can discover from that so I can
now make wood planks which I'm going to
do real quick so I have a wood plank
this is pretty linear but once I do this
I can make a wood stick and now we start
getting a little more complicated so I
can do something like this
now you notice these two are highlighted
which means these two can go together
and through experimentation I can now
make an animal trap which will pop up
here in just a second that's something
we can plop into the world and it's
going to catch rabbits and things and be
able to kill that rabbit cook it over a
fire and have a good time hopefully with
the full belly and not getting murdered
by wildlife in our game real quick a
couple these things we're finding right
here oh my god I'm going to get killed
by a wolf are some more high-end things
within our games so there are
foundations that I'm grabbing from this
container right here now foundations are
your intro to building into the game
we'll show that here in just a little
bit but typically this would take a
player a long time to accomplish takes a
lot of materials to build into our world
so we're going to go ahead and show that
off regardless just so everyone get a
taste of what to expect
but back to the discovery for just a
moment I
to inventory space from the backpack I
just picked up I am going to grab this
this time actually first I'm going to
take my shirt off because why not every
excuse take your shirt off is a good one
right so I have some cloth now so I'm
going to take this cloth I'm going to
take this wood stick and this is still
highlighted it's animal fat and all
these together are going to actually
come out to a torch so I can now make my
favorite melee weapon in the game for
probably obvious reasons fires great
fires good we learned pretty quickly
while giving them to players in the
beginning like the first thing you get
when you spawn is a torch is a bad idea
suddenly everything burns to ashes and
people are screaming at each other at
the office and it just wasn't exactly a
desirable experience right off the bat
vehicles in our game which I just jumped
into here are got to be found in various
states of disrepair right so these
things are going to be missing a wheel
they're going to be missing batteries
this one's a pretty good shape just so
we can kind of run around show the
dynamics of them we are leveraging the
planetside 2 forged light engine for
those may be familiar with that which
has a really dynamic tuning system for
vehicles in that particular game we have
everything from a quad like little
four-wheeler all the way up to tanks
into aircrafts so we can do a lot with
this game as we move forward
so right up here I'm going to stop and
I'm going to plop down a foundation real
quick yeah it's going to look a little
wonky because I didn't craft this all
together that would normally take a
while but I am going to right click here
and click place this is going to pop up
this is a more high-end foundation you
can see it's on stilts this is your
beginning to putting a permanent
footprint into the world so I'm going to
run up top here there's going to be
actually we have it in right now right
now only have these pre crafted little
areas we decided we're going to try to
see what players think of having some
pre crafted buildings that cost a little
more in resources but they're easy to
plop down and they're just kind of and
you put this down and have some storage
I need a cord in this area off I don't
want to put the walls down so here's a
shed
now preformed walls all the way around
you have your doors in the roof and
everything else but for right now this
is something we've been talking about
and trying to get in right before early
access and let's see what players think
about is instead of just having a home
that's just something to live in or just
store things then you could be more
survivalist and be more self sustainable
like in our world it's a
post-apocalyptic like I won't even drink
out of the lake in the Oklahoma where
I'm from where there might be 2,000
people much less in a world where things
might have gone nuts so you can take an
empty bottle which chute I don't have
right now you can actually run out here
fill an empty bottle it'll give you
dirty water if you get it from most
water sources and it's going to hurt you
you can filter and boil that water out
if you'd like but really later on as you
start building your own claims in areas
this is a do collector and it'll it'll
be a consistent source of fresh water
it'll take time as well as catch rain
obviously the way this is set up which
by the way this is a more optimistic
northwestern type day this is some of
the days we are going to bring in the
clouds here every day at a certain time
it's going to decide what the next day
will be like these are the two extremes
very very clear day and very very cloudy
you can go anywhere between those two
and it will also pick what type of
precipitation you'll see for that day it
can go anywhere from a very basic light
drizzle which may be a little bit hard
to see on stream it's a very light all
the way up to something like this will
almost immediately affect the world in
multiple ways your character gets wet
you can see your weapon itself actually
shines in the light and everything and
the water will start pulling on the
ground now that's going to affect your
character in the way that your clothes
are wet if it's cold outside you need to
get out of it and you need to be careful
you can get
sick and beyond that vehicle dynamics
are obviously going to change as well
because wet roads and different types of
vehicles will react differently
currently you're going to find yourself
when you get into the game actually
gonna run over here and grab a little
bit more wood right now in the game when
you first start off and you want to
build a campfire especially if it's
raining outside I can actually go
directly underneath like this so you're
gonna go through want to craft a quick
campfire and I'm gonna put it down right
right here so it's actually not raining
on me right now oh I'm sorry it was on
campfire might just be on the inside
perfect so you can actually keep
yourself dry keep yourself warm over the
night obviously it's dangerous to be out
here in the wide open with a source of
light at night but it's still better
than the alternative of dying of
hypothermia over the next couple days
they're all also the options we did a
12-hour twitch livestream where we left
community decide what we were going to
develop for them within 12 hours from
beginning to end and it was barricades
so barricades will also allow the player
to find pre-existing homes within the
world that we've placed as designers and
residential areas or the milliner where
there are cabins and take those over for
themselves permanently or temporarily I
doubt permanence will be a thing because
you put barricades on windows it's a big
flag saying hey I'm in here crafting
right now so it is a good way to get out
of the rain though and board things up
and be safe from zombies as long as
you're quiet I'm going to swap this out
real quick weapons in our game like
assault rifles are not craftable we
don't want that to be the case it's a
little weird to fully craft a stamped
assault rifle that's made by experts in
the field straight out of a forge that's
homemade so you'll have to scavenge
high-end weapons like the the ar-15s the
m16s the 1911's and all that sort of
stuff I want you to quickly note how
much ammo I have right now so around 120
bullets total and this seems like a
relatively small engagement
it's not the one what I'm going to do is
I'm try to bring these guys over to me
it is a little dark outside so if I make
noise and they don't see me they're
drawn to the noise and actually these
guys obviously saw me that was a
horrible attempt at what I was trying to
do I'm going to run the house real quick
engaging these guys directly even if I
had enough ammo to take them all down
probably still wouldn't be a good idea
they may not be as fast as me but there
are a lot of them you get yourself in
close quarters they can quickly
overwhelm you so I'm going to try to run
through here
and it looks like we're gonna be oh my
god in a lot of trouble so I am just for
the fun of it just for the sake of a
demo going to do something I personally
because my playstyle would never do in
the game try to correctly take on and so
far not so hot I'm already down to just
90 bullets left from the long run fast
enough to chill up these guys actually
see if we can actually jump back in and
get a good bearing on at least one up
everything's still catching one of those
guys on fire it's some sort of light
source over on one which was a guy on
fire so it's gone now and I think I'm
I'm still alive never mind I'm actually
going to make this so I'm gonna try to
run back to the car now one of the best
courses of action it's kind of a last
resort thing vehicles going to be very
important in this game and by running
zombies over over and over and over
again you're going to start doing damage
to your vehicle but this is a last
resort type situation where I could keep
running but I wouldn't be able to pay
much attention could run into a wolf or
something so I'm gonna jump in the
off-roader and have fun with the ragdoll
that we've put in screens a little dark
right now so for the sake of the demo if
hopefully you don't mind I'm going to
hit this fancy button that brings my
health back to normal
don't expect that nearly excess guys but
yeah beyond that just a couple quick
things that we are a full 24 hour day
night cycle game this is a day at noon
on a rainy gloomy day you may hey dude
we do it
you may recognize this from the Pacific
Northwest type area is really what we're
trying to go for here and yeah
definitely excited to get to early
access get a couple more features we're
working on we want to make sure that we
have things like thrown in the game we
will not launch go to early access
without prone we will not go without the
basics of durability which are very much
rapidly coming online we want to make
sure that it's the game you guys expect
when it gets early access well that guys
that's h1z1 in a nutshell there's a lot
more to come it every day more and more
things are coming online I hope you guys
enjoy it stay tuned h1z1 calm at h1z1
game on Twitter and of course I'm Jimmy
wasn't hunt and that's at Jimmy whiz
please stay in touch with us and stay
tuned for more streams